c'est lui le vainqueur michael stanislas
il rencontre la première étape du coach
du cos cantona aux données au moins
cette fois ma victoire ici ce magnifique
lui aussi au pub du coup c'est pour mon
travail qui me libère beaucoup appuyé
sur ses résultats donc il ya tout en
oeuvre pour que puisse faire de bons
résultats ici donc voilà si fallait se
battre jusqu'à la fin se sont retrouvés
14 heures pile les 117 engagé à cette
quatrième édition s'élance on se
confronter sur les routes du sud
au menu plus de 117 km nous sommes au
septième c'est la station de bois-rouge
lieu très prisé des fanatiques de la
petite reine
ici au sommet de bois rouge mickaël
laurent numéro de alvin sommes cachés
des tâches mais derrière le peloton
pointe le nez à cet esprit c'est un
peloton groupé qui se dirigeaient aval
at devant il y a trois fuyards dont
violence ilves numéro 23 s'est dit que
ce stage le 2 et kevin large it dans les
lacets les efforts de guerre call up
numéro 53 sont payants il recolle au
groupe de tête après le vauclin c'est la
montée de coups au baril aux marins les
hommes de tête sont suivis à 30 secondes
de neuf coureurs
[Musique]
à sainte luce les hommes de tête
possèdent plus de deux minutes sur leurs
poursuivants l'écart reste le même vers
7 est ce qu'on en voit
[Musique]
à 4 3 et série costa chimiques et
stanislas lutte pour la gagne
les deux garçons conjuguent leurs
efforts et c'est cela nice l'as le plus
fort à des gosses eustache et ce beau n
est encore joué donc j'espère pouvoir
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit j'espère
pouvoir vraiment faire la différence sur
le chrono et pouvoir bien me placer
troisième violente sylvest du madinina
bikers demain 14h contre-la-montre
sainte luce a plus à 21 kilomètres
attendent des coureurs